就是我们平时常说的rd g
那也就是现仰依赖图
那现在我们现在看到的呢
这个是官方的文档呃
如果是不太熟悉的同学呢
我是非常建议呃
完整的去阅读一下官方的这个这个文档的介绍
那对我们的了解呢
它是呃为什么要这样子去做
他想实现一个什么样的一个特性
以及官方的一个直译
是对于我们了解这个模块是非常有帮助的
那么这个RDG呢其实呢就是一个优化的技术
前面我们已经了解到
我们会把各种各样的渲染的命令
去组组装在一起
就形成一个pass
一组渲染命令
一个i hi多个hi的指令组成了一组
完成了某一种功能
比如说是渲染一个深度图
比如说是复制一张纹理
或者诸如此类
或者是进行一些光照的某个计算
那么这样一组的IHI的命令
它就是所谓的一个pass
那么呃一个完整的渲染
那就是由很多个pass去组成
那么这个渲染依赖图呢
也就是IDG呢
它就是解决这样一个问题
就是pass与pass之间呢它是有依赖关系的
就是说某些pass它必须是依赖于另外一个pass
它必须先完成别的pass的一些计算
才才能接着往下去去执行
那么像这样子呢
就利用这种rd g的技术去计算
统计pass与pass之间的一种依赖关系
然后我们就可以在这个基础上去做很多优化
做很多异步的计算
那具体的一些呃呃为什么啊
有什么功能啊
官方的文档都解析的很清晰啊
那么我们来看一眼呢
就是说常规的一个pass是怎样子的
我们拉到中间这里呢
就是有一个一个pass
它大体长什么样子
比如说你写了一个C的
你写了一段C的
完成了某一段功能
那当然了
你像前面一样
你要去继承这个global c的
然后去实现一下这个C的类
实现你自己的C的类
然后你要定义你的着色器的参数
也要定义一些参数结构
然后完成你这个着色器的定义
最后你要在某个合适的地方去调用
你这个C的的执行
那么就是所谓的an的一个pass
就是比如说在某些某个渲染的地方调用
你就叫C的
那它的流程呢就是大概就是第一
你先构造出你的着色器的参数
然后去填充你着色器真正使用的一些参数
填充完之后
我们就会把这个pass添加进去
添加进去
那么这样一个pass添加进去
实际上这张pass是做什么呢
就是后面传入的这个lambda的这个函数
这里就是真正的i hi的一些指令
他当然了
他并不是在这个时候去执行
他是把这个lambda保存起来
然后在RDG去分析编译
最后去执行
那么它是延迟延延延迟执行的
那这样子
在这个过程中就可以做很多优化的工作
那比如说由于常规的优化是什么
比如说两个pass之间有前后依赖关系
但是两个pass之间他是不是要加资源的转换呢
是不是一定要做的
有些时候是不需要的
比如说这两个pass它用到的贴图是一样的
它的呃一些标记额是一样的
那么这个时候pass与pass之间
它可能就可以省下这种啊
这种评价barrier的一些调用
因为前面的前面并没有去改变或者是怎么样
那后面是接着前面的
后面这个pass跟前面的pass直接就调用起来了
因为当你要正常情况下
你要去执行一个pass
正常情况是什么
你要先把所有的状态
比如说pipeline dps
比如说一些资源了
你用到了一些贴图对吧
前面是
读取状态或者是写的状态
后面这个pass呢要把它变成一张la target或者怎么样
那你要做这个资源的转换
但是如果某两个pass之间
他根本就不需要去做这种话
那你可以把这个东西跳过
就不用去执行是吧
那这就是优化
所以这个rd g呢它其实是一个优化的技术
然后呢他着重的处理呢
就是pass与pass之间的一个依赖关系
呃这个官方文档我们不会在这里看太多哈
我只是说是一开始先给大家同学们介绍一下哈
自己去官方的文档
去去搜索这个这个IDG就可以了
去了解一下是非常有帮助的
这个讲了非常多实实在在的东西
但我们还是回过头来
着重的去了解一下代码的一些关键的步骤
因为有些时候啊哈有些时候你看代码
你直接看代码
好像每一行代码都很都很简单
但是你如果没有一个目标是看代码会比较慢啊
就会因为你不知道他到底要做什么
如果你有很清晰
你先了解一下哦
原来他的目标就是要做这件事
那自然而然你看代码就会快很多哈
就是啊给大家一个提示
那我们呢回过头来RDGIDG
我们要先看下基础的一些类
看一下的一些资源
然后看下一个pass大体上是长什么样子
然后再看一下啊
pass pass之间的依赖是怎么样的
怎么去剔除一些没用的pass
合并一些pass
那大体上的流程就是这样
那我们先看一下
先从一些熟悉基础的类型开始熟悉哈
一个pass呢就是把一堆渲染指令啊封装在一起呢
就是一个rd g pass i d g pass rd g模块呢
它基本上所有的东西都是RDG开头的
这是一个rd g的pass
就是呃一般来说就是一个lambda
它实际上会继承一个lambda的子类
然后把lambda保存起来
而lambda呢就是上层在写的时候去调用那些
i hi的一些渲染指令
然后呢这个handle
这个i d g handle是什么东西呢
Rd g handle
其实你可以理解为就是一个嗯一个索引
一个索引或者是一个数组的下标
它有点像windows的那种handle的概念啊
反正就是说你根据一个handle
你就可以找到呃对应的真正的那个类的对象
它实际上是在呃某个地方有一个数组
然后把它转换成一个index
然后找到那个对象的下标
就是找到那个对象
就就这个handle呢
就是后面因为我们会阅读代码的时候
会经常看的话
就是说handle呢
你可以理解它就是一个对象的数组的
所以下标
所以呢你可以根据这个handle
去找到真正的对象
这是一个handle呃
然后然后是registry
LEGISCH是什么东西呢
其实它就是一个数组嗯
这个是LEGISTRY嗯
我看了下他家往下翻
对
他其实就是一个对对对象类型的
那个目标类型的一个指针的数组
就是一个工厂类吗
或者是一个注册类
你可以理解它它就是一个数组这个模板类
这是个模板类模板类
所以呢registry呢你就知道它是一个数组
嗯然后die rain的那这个就很明显了
就是array了哈
就是数组了
呃然后还有一个rd机成的资源
资源也是非常重要的一个这个资源
我们看一下资源类
哦我们之前曾经看过有关于渲染资源哈
在RHI层有i hi的resource
然后呢那个是在hi层面的抽象
然后我们也还看到逻辑层在更上层一点
有F层的resource
就是f resource
就比如说一张贴图
我们会有hi的TE
那个就是真正的I真正的啦
就是继承了IHIT
我们就比如说在第三第12里面会有一个第三
第12的texture或者是uniform buffer之类的
然后那个是真正的哈
那个真正真的是DX12
DX11或者是open gl里面的那种吗哈
然后呢在那个基础上
我们也封装了一个F层的一个texture
L城的TENTION呢
其实里面就包含一个IHIH的指针
或者相关的索引的信息
然后以及其他的一些封装
然后比如说一些贴图呢
我们还有UU字母开头的那个资源
比如说我们在蓝图里面经常看到的u texture
2d
那个就是我们在写蓝图的时候看到的那个封装
那它里面当然也是在i hi层面的
基础上去进行封装
那么rd居城它也封装了一个资源
也是IDG开头的resource
那么在RDG层面
它也是拥有i hi层面的一个封装
那就比如说你看gay h i
它就是里面就是有一个成员变量
有RHR成员的那个
但是RD居城的resource有一个特征
所有的RDG的资源有个特征
它除了封装了i hi层面的资源
它有一个延迟的特征
也就是说当你去创建一个rd g层面的资源
不管是贴图也好
uniform buffer也好
他并不会在那个时候去真正的创建
RHI层面的资源
而是只是注册了一个RDG层面的资源
当你真正去调用
去执行去sq你的pass的时候
真的需要用到那张资源的时候
他才会去创建真正的i hi前面的这些
那么这样子就就出现了一种延时的封装
就是说呃可以
你现在先嗯酷睿I1个i d g resource
表示我这个bus要用到一张贴图
或者是ur uniform buffer
然后因为本身你这个IDGE的pass
本身就是啊收集起来后面慢慢执行的
那也就是后面执行的时候才用
为什么要这样子操作的
因为我们RNG是要做什么
我们rd g本身就是要去分析那些
pass与pass之间的依赖关系
因为很有可能某一些pass是可以剔除的
是根本对我这一帧的画面是没有贡献的
是没用的
我们是可以把这个pass剔除的
那你本身都把这个p pass剔除了
那就pass相关的资源
其实本身也是没有必要去创建的
对不对
那所以它的特征就是一开始先不会去创建
i hi层面的这些
后面要的时候
那这个我们后面看到代码的时候
也会稍微有点了解
所以呢嗯在RDG层面
它也封装了一个RDG层面的资源
它内部也会有hi层面的资源
所以你并不是什么时候
你拿到了RDG的resource啊
我就一定能get到这个RHI它有时候是没有的
因为你还没执行这个就是没有了哈
嗯那比如说我们看一个rd g的texture
那比如说IDG这里是i d g resource
那比如说那他自然也有FRDG
这个就是RDG的
那他是继承一个vable resource
vable resource就是继承了resource
那就是类似这样继承它
那它也有那也有它的描述
它的flag
然后有它对应的hi对应的hi tech这些它的内凹
诸如此类
他也是一样类似的去封装好
那么对于rd g层面的资源
统一都是由RDG的模块去管理的
因此呢你并不能自己随便的去new rd g的类的
那个对象
你要用统一的方法去去做
而这些资源的方法的提供呢
是在RNG builder里面的
就是这个嗯就是FRDG
builder这个类里面
它提供了很多方法
比如说creature
Creattention
你要用那这个REF就是2DG
然后再加一个加一个引用哈
它其实就是它的指针了
哈哈好
那么我们对基本的一些类的了解哈
就是呃有一些基础的类什么handle啊
那其实是一个指针
LEGISTRY呢其实就是数组
那就是这些handle
其实就是索引或者是指针或者是下标
反正是根据它
然后从一个数组里面就能拿到真正的对象
然后LEGISC呢其实就是一个数组
然后呃重点呢就是另外两个类
一个是pass
就是封装了一堆指令
然后最所有的时间就是这个builder
我们到时候会着重看这个builder的实现
好嗯那builder里面就提供了很多很多方法
就比如说我们要去一个一个执行一段一个pass
构建一个pass是吧
有那个SHADER的参数
有我们用到的就是texture
那么像这个test这些资源
这些参数呢
你就要用RNG builder提供的方法去去创建
比如说我们看到这个IDG的builder里面是吧
有这些create的方法
什么create buffer s r v tu vv
你就要用这些方法去创建
那么还有一种情况
还有一种情况
就比如说本身我在外面已经有这张texture了
难道我还要去这里QA一下吗
呃如果你是本身就已经拥有了某张贴图
比如说这张贴图是外部传过来的
你比如说一张模型的贴图
那么这个时候呢
你就要用你在这个build里面去注册
那么就是用register的方法
它也有这种啊
register external buffa test讲
这就是它的数
就是说呃你要把一张普通的
比如说普通的什么PTARGET传进来
然后由这个builder去构建一个rd
g texture的类的对象
当然了
它就会在里面设置一些布尔值
到时候就能正确处理
因为这张真正的纹理呢是在外部的
所以它不会把你的释放掉
但是你也要去注册
不然你就用不了
也就是说如果你是一开始完全没有的字的贴图
或者是buffer
那么你就要用他的create的方法
如果你是外面本身已经
比如说别的地方已经有了这个i hi的texture
或者是那你当你去构建一个RNG pass的时候
你用到了它
那么你也要register出来
这样子去构建rd g的层面上的
那这个这个里面其实具体的实践就很简单
其实只是只是new一个这样的对象
然后把RRHR全面设置进去
然后它其实在里面呢就会呃设置一些簸箕啊
就标记它它是外部注册进来的
到时候你去清理资源啊
或者怎么样的时候你要注意就是外部的
你你整个rd g系统呢
你不要不要轻易的把它删掉就OK了
那这个是builder呃
这个呢就是呃注册关于一些资源上的了解
那么资源一般就是texture和Buff啊这些东西了
然后呢还有一个是extraction
比如说嗯我们找一下
这个
这
里有一个extraction
这个观概念是什么呢
就是说呃这个贴图在整个pass执行完以后
这张贴图要不要输出到外部系统去
还是这个EXTRON
就是说呃比如说你这一杆pass呃
生成了某一张贴图
或者是一张呃深度图
或者是一个STL或者是什么
那么生成了就就结束了吗
还是说这张贴图
你是需要保存成外面的另外一个东西的
一个render target
如果你是需要的
你不仅在添加pass的时候要做这件事
你还要调这个接口去处理
这个就很重要了
为什么
因为他就是用来判断一个pass到底是否有必要
是否有作用的一个很关键很关键的判断标准
你想想你添加了一个pass
这个pass输出经过渲染输出来一张贴图
但是这张贴图在后续根本就没用了
结束了
那那就叫pass
是不是意味着其实不执行也没所谓的呀
对不对
是不是嘛
虽然你你你执行了一段很很非常复杂的算法
然后输出了一张非常厉害的截图
或者是渲染出一张很厉害的东西
然后没有了没用啊
因为你后续没有用到它
没有用到它
意味着这个pass对你这个整个屏幕看到的画面
是没有作用的呀
所以这个pass就可以剔除掉
因为但凡你不能被剔除掉的
意味着要么你这个pass是被别的pass依赖了
而别的pass最后的输出一定是最形成一条链条
一定是有用的
什么用途
要么就输出到屏幕画面嘛
某个窗口吧
或者说你保存出去嘛
那么既然你需要把这个pass输出的这个贴图
或者怎么样要用到
比如说哈呃某些光光线的算法
他要用这一帧the stal深度的图
作为下一帧某个算法的输入
所以他就要extraction
他就要把把这个pass执行完了
然后把当前的那个什么STLE啊
或者之类的输出给下一帧用啊
那我们举个例子
我们去看那个the fin slla
OK我们去找那个
我们看一个例子
自FDEF
Defer seating sller
然后他的render函数
嗯可能要往下滚
闻到很下面
诶
是这里吗
不就是mobile了
这样的对我往下翻一翻
应该比较后面一点
OKOK你看这里
那这里就是前面这把添加了很多pass执行
执行了很多东西
暂时不管
你看他就要告诉你这个过拉菲builder
到时候你要把这张Deft的深度图保存起来
保存在哪里
保存成我的这个def buffer
这里实际上是做什么用途呢
就是把当前这一帧的深度贴图解压出来
并保存到这个depth buffer这里
这个depth buffer呢
又在下一帧作为某一个输入就来用
那你想想你有了有了这句话
有了这句话
是不是
就意味着这个depth这张贴图是必定要执行的
而跟这个depth相关的所有的pass
它是绝对不可以被剔除的
那么depth所依赖的pass
以及这些pass依赖的所有pass它都要执行
但是如果某一个pass它既不被别人pass依赖
而最终他所输出的所有贴图
所有用到的buffer贴图都没用
那其实我们最后就可以把它删掉
那这个就是RDG的剔除算法的
最为关键的一个要素
所以呢所以呢这个extraction也是要重点了解哈
extraction就是
这个那么关于贴图资源呢
关于贴图资源呢
第一你要么就是调这个graph builder
这个类的create方法去创建
要么你如果是外部的呢
你就要用外部的传进来
然后让它register注册
然后他返回一个IDG的类的对象给你
然后呢
你对于这张这个贴这个pass
生成的某些贴图或者怎么样
你如果是有用的
你就要证明这个queen这个attraction
而这个attraction后面就涉及到我们非常重要的
依赖的那个判断好
那么再更进一步来了解这个graphic builder
它是怎么计算依赖关系以及怎么剔除
怎么合并
我们先再看一下一个pass它是怎么样
虽然我们知道一个pass就是一段一段lambda
那这个pass呢就是这个类r d g pass
那这个i d g pass呢
它其实啊看一下成员变量啊
就是有一个名字
有一些呃flag
然后有一次pine
pine呢就是一般现在就两个
一个就是计算
另外一个就是古拉菲图形
就目前来说就两个
那就是一个graph的
就是要有光栅化啊
有有有有这个阶段的
那这个呢就纯粹的只是计算的啊
OK就是两个PELINE
就是当前它是哪些play play
然后以及一个pass
你用到的那些着色器的参数是吧
着色器的参数要保存起来
还要拉一个handle
他自己的handle就是指针啊
就类似这些
然后呢呃这些后面我们再再看
然后呢他提供了一个EQ的函数函数
因为这只是一个父类
只是一个父类
那么真正真正最常用的呢是继承它
并且实现了一个XQ的方法
那就是兰姆达
注意这里有几个有几个很重要的
来了解一下这个这个呢是一个pass handle的数组
也就是说一个pass它记录着一组的handle
就是一堆别的pass的指针或者是索引
那这个其实producer是什么意思呢
produce duce就是生产者消费者的一个概念
就是这一个pass当前它依赖了哪些pass
就pass与pass之间是有依赖关系的
producer就是说依赖了别的pass
比如说我现在是pass a
但是呢我这个pass a依赖了pass bcd
也就是说我必须要让BCD这三个pass
他输出先输出
先执行或者怎么样
他比如说输出了某张纹理
它的纹理在作为我的输入或者之类的
有依赖关系的
或者说我要等pass b执行完才能执行对吧
因为它它它生成一张贴图
他没pass b CD没执行完
我pass a就不能执行
我就要在那里等待
诸如此类
那这个producer就是BCD
98在pass a里面就记录着BCD
那这个produce就是依赖关系
后面我们看这个produce怎么用
这个成员变量非常重要啊
那然后还有一堆成员变量
就是这一堆就是这个pass它用到了哪些资源
贴图buffer威武uniform
而且都是数组
那这些东西怎么来的呢
这些东西还记得我们以前在写那个
说那个CD的时候
不是要用一个红去构建一个结构体吗
一个参数吗
就是从那个东西去分析出来的
那么一个pass用到了哪些参数
用到了哪些贴图
用到了哪些buffer
就是到时候会解析出来放在这里面
所以一个pass呃
它有它会记录着他依赖的pass
它会记录着他用到的哪些资源啊
那其实还有很多
暂时我们先关注这些好
那么有了这个pass的积累
我们下面就继承它
实现了一个lambda pass
lambda pass是一个模板类
这个模板就是lambda
那么实际上就是把这个lambda保存起来
就是
它保存成一个成员变量
把这个lambda保存成一个成员变量
到时候并且实现这个execute的方法
到时候sq的方法
其实就是去执行这个lambda的函数
执行这个lambda函数
所以呢呃一段pass保存起来
其实就是把那个lambda存储起来
延迟执行
等
真正要去执行这个pass的时候
才去执行对应的lambda的那个函数
那这个其实就是最常用的
其实到时候我们一个A1个pass
然后把那个lambda传进来
其实就是这个模板类
这个就是一个pass的封装
好
嗯那现在我们最后就来看一下关键的部分
其实就是这个build
就是这个build我们有了一些基础资源
我们对IDG的资源稍微了解一下
它其实就是在原来的基础上又封装了一套
然后把pass也封装了一套
其实就是把那一个最重要的
把拉姆达的那个渲染指令给存储起来
后面延迟执行
然后我们看哈
我们看官方文档
看官方文档我们真正要用一个pass是怎么用吗
看这里官方文档的这个介绍
你看你你怎么样
一开始你去构建参数
然后设置好你的参数
最后怎么样
你就是一个pass到这个图里面去嘛
就把这个pass添加进去吗
这个pass就自带的把你这个参数嘛
着色器的参数吗
然后类型嘛
然后这个就是那个lambda嘛
对不对
这几句话这里面就是存储着整个lambda
也就是先元指令嘛
就是i hr1C什么C的SC的参数
或者是调i hi的一些方法嘛
那这些就是把这些IHI的渲染指令
存储起来吗
到时候这个pass真正去执行的时候
他不就是到时候执行这一段函数嘛
对不对
那实际上就是要添加一个pass
这就是A的一个pass好
那我们看一下graphic builder
那graphic builder除了提供常规的
比如说这些查找啊
天create create资源啊
或者是register资源啊
还有loco
就是用他的方法来创建这个参数
这些是基础的一些资源的相关的函数
那么重要的呢就是那个at pass
我们看at pass
其实就是把你看最后一个参数就是一个lambda
把这个lambda传进来
然后然后存储起来
其实就是把这个lambda保存起来
然后并生成一个pass的对象
然后这个pass呢就怕添加到全局数组里面
这个pass就是所有pass的一个数组
register群就是一个数组
我们刚才看过了哈
那就是一个数组哈
这个类似区刚才我们一开始可浏览
所以呢所有的pass就在这里面
那么到时候那个handle其实就是这个pass
这里面的一个下标索引
就把
呃这个pass生成出来添加进去
然后设置的初始化
然后在初始化的时候
大概会有一个setup dependency
我看一下
USA是这里吗
啊对在后面
那我们看到一个pass
大概要一开始要有哪些东西呢
我们刚才看pass的类的时候啊
这个pass的类第一个呢当然是他的资源对吧
我们往刚才已经看过他的一些重要的成员变量
就是
在哪里
啊对这个pass用到了什么资源
然后还有这个pass它依赖了哪些
别的pass就是那个producer
producer去哪里了
在前面啊
对就是这个
那这个可以说是一个pass很重要的两部分
那这个就是pass的依赖关系
这个呢就是pass的资源
那么所以我们在一开始添加at pass的时候
就要弄好这些东西
那么其实它就是在这个app pass之前
它就会set up这个pass的source
就是我们回跳回去再看一遍
那看到没有啊
当你去ADD一个pass
他直接就会调到这个airpods internal
然后就是一开始先相当于是new一个对象出来
然后添加进去
然后把这个lambda已经保存起来了
然后我们就要初始化好它
初始化好它就重要分两部分
一个是资源
另外一个是依赖关系
资源呢就是这个这个parameter struck
这个就是前面我们说过了那个那个什么layout
那个什么seed palameter的那些红
然后那个递归关系就是前面两节呃
我们讲了那个通过一个红展开之后
递归去把他的所有成员变量收集起来
把一个着色器的那个参数收集起来
保存在某个地方
那现在就是把它拿出来
那把它拿出来
我当然就知道这个这个参数它用到了哪些贴图
用到了哪些uniform buffer了
对不对
那就是把它提取出来嘛
你看他就是这个
大概在这里吧
那这个是传进来的参数
传进来的参数
枚举它所有的贴图
他怎么枚举它所有的贴图啊
你看嘛就是把它的内out这个类啊
就是那个metadata搞出来的
看到没看到这个
Panameters struck
然后这个
哎呀哎
应该是他
那这个这个这个这个还记得吧
我们如果不记得了
翻一下前面两两节的那个视频哈
就是我们会再有一个宏把它展开
会把每个成员变量的那个那个类型啊
那个成员变量的类型名字
还有他的那个成员变量的那个指针的偏移
这些全部记录下来
那现在就是把这个成员变量的指针的偏移嘛
加上去
然后强行转换成这个那个parameter嘛
然后就是相当于是
我能拿到所有的所有的参数嘛
然后再根据这个type
这个type是什么
这个type就是各种各样的类型吗
你是不or int还是texture
那我现在就知道你哪个是什么
对不对
如果你是texture
那我就强行的把它转换成text就OK了吗
全新的把它转换成texture嘛
然后就就就相当于是
现在就是能拿到所有的贴图吗
所以呢现在就是在setup这个pass的资源的时候
我就可以从之前的那个反射的信息里面呃
拿到设置这些pass它有哪些贴图
它有哪些buffer
那就是设置这个
这一堆信息资源的信息
这对这对信息计算下
就全部在这个位置上设置好了
好第二个信息
那就是设计
其实我们的重点就是依赖关系
那就是在往下面有一个setup pass的dependency
就是依赖关系
那它是怎么设计的呢
我们稍微过一点一个pass
它其实是怎么去依赖别的pass
其实是根据资源来决定这个依赖关系的
也就是说
我当前的这个pass是不是用到了一张贴图
那这张贴图是不是又有别的pass生成的
那如果这张贴图我现在pass a用到了一张贴图
然后这张贴图是由pass b生成的
那我是不是就意味着我的pass a要依赖pass b
是这个逻辑吧
那就是按照这个原理
所以设置这个依赖关系
其实就是便利我当前这个pass的所有贴图
便利我这个pass的所有buffer
然后找出buffer跟贴图
他们又是依赖哪些别的pass
然后就添加进去
那这个texture的一开始在创建的时候呢
我们看一下这个texture本身就是记录者
一个producer的producer
其实就是呃依赖依赖关系
就是应该是在
鸡肋吧
我刚刚是在鸡肋还是在哪里
那应该是叫resource
这个鸡肋应该有个producer
有没有
那难道是这这以前吗
看一下
这个是不是produce
但是那个produce应该有一个produce的
哦没事没事
我们看代码
等下肯定会找到这个变量的
你看他怎么建立这个pass dependency
它便利这张在当前这个pass所用到的所有贴图
这个就是贴图buffer资源遍历每一张便利
每一张贴图
对对对
这个last duce就是他里面其实是一个producer stay
这是个数组哈
就是有很在当前这张贴图啊
这个是i dg texture
它里面有一个数组
这个数组里面是记录着什么
记录着
它依它依赖了哪个pass
然后对应的枚举这个类型
还有一些NO uvb的handle
那重点是这个这么了解
这就是producer
就是就是依赖依赖谁生产了它对吧
谁生产的生产者
所以呢一个r d g texture
一个dd texture的类里面是有一组
producer的有很多producer的哈
那么
现在我要建新建一个新增一个pass
我就要把当前这些pass便利它所有的贴图
然后对于每一个贴图又要便利它所有的生产者
便利每一张贴图
每一张贴图的每一个生产者
然后去判断
那如果是什么unknown的
就就就就不理
那然后就添加一个dependency
添加一个就是说呃
你这张贴图的生产者跟我现在
那这个这个就是我嘛
这个就是我自己嘛
对不对
把这两个当成参数调用
这个函数就是建立一个依赖关系
就是我当前这个pass依赖了这个pass
当然了
它里面还有一个细节要去判断
是不是
比如说是不是真的有必要去建立这个依赖关系
那他他判断条件就很简单
就是说如果如果他们的pipeline是相同的
那就一定要如果pine不相同
那可能就不用
那他还要判断一下他们的这些什么
ur v barrier是不是一样
然后呃类似
接近三
如果确认判断条件通过
那就把它添加进去
添加进去就是什么
就是在producer里面加进去
producer就是那这个producer
就是每个pass都有一组producer
就是当前这个pass依赖了哪些别的pass
懂了吧
那这个很重要哈
但是太忙了
其实并不复杂哈
代码并不复杂
那这样子就就建立了这个依赖关系
同样道理
贴图是这样
那buffer也是一样
那buffer一样也有他的那个不能丢
然后也一样的添加进去
但中间也会判断那些那几个什么PAPI
是不是一样
那假如就这样吧
然后这个这个上面部分是建立依赖关系
这三这几句话呢是用来做剔除
请问什么样的东西可以剔除
什么东西不可以剔除呃
这个东西呢
这个枚举值呢就是说它能不能被能不能剔除
能不能剔除
默认呢先现在第一次添加这个pass进来
全部都是true
全部都是一
就是说莫先初始化全部都是true
后面他再来设置
也就是说嗯所有的pass都可以剔除
然后我们最后再根据某些条件
把那些不可剔除的真正的刷新
它这个布尔值到时候没刷新
闹的你还是处的
那就真的把你踢出了
那怎么样
那它就会添加到这里来
那什么样的东西
什么东西是要添加这里来呢
添加到这里来呢
就是就是有用的
这个这个是that就能添加到这个数组里面
就表示这个pass是一定是有用的
怎么样只是有用的呢
那就是呃你是有对外输出的
有对外有输出的
或者是外部添加pass的上层逻辑
你强行的设置了那个flag
你说他绝对不能被剔除
OK那那那那这个rd g这个系统
它也就一定会把你添加进来
就你要么就是强行设置它绝对不能剔除
要么就是判断了你是有对外输出输出
就是你queen了那个register那个extraction
刚才我们说你的QU了
或者一些其他好
那注意哈
虽然添加就是某些特殊的
那比如说至少哪些pass是一定会添加到这里来啊
是不是你那一张最后的pass
要输出最后的画面的那个pass
就是你要记你前面可能计算完深度了
计算完呃什么颜色啊
最后你真的输出最终的那个最最最最后的那个
后处理那个pass
然后那个一执行完就已经要把那个buffer交换链
要把它交换到屏幕屏幕上
窗口上的那个
是不是一定要要有external or那个pass
就就一定要添加到这里来嘛
对不对
那到时候我们怎么计算贴图
是不是还没不用看
大家都已经大概了解了
那就是从那个pass开始
遍历那个pass又依赖了哪些pass
然后那些pass又依赖了哪些pass
然后把所有递归的去找出
他前面依赖了所有的pass
那就是不可以被提出的
然后在整个递归找的过程中
如果发现有一些pass怎么都找不到
那那那不好意思
你就可以被剔除了
就是这个原理哈
好UT厨
剔除大概是在
执行前有一个comply函数啊
OK现在有这个builder呢
有三个函数啊
比较重要
一个是at
那就现在现在添加一个pass进来
就是at
那么它就会初始化好这些资源
初始化好这些依赖关系
然后同时默认设置这个呃
唯一默认先设置为一
然后某会初始有某些pass是关键的
必不可缺的
会添加到这个数组里面来
然后等到执行前
他会执行那个compile函数嗯
应该是compile函数编译在执行前会执行这个
嗯我看看
这个就是到这个
编译编译呢实际上就是会初始化一些东西了
我们记得吧
我们前面讲过RDG的资源其实是没有
一开始是就算你create了
但真正他也不会创建i hi资源哈
他是在这里面去支持
他
是在sq之前去执行了
那这里呢就会做一些初始化的工作
稍微有有点复杂
但是我们的重点呢是看那个剔除
剔除呢大概是在
很简单就这里很简单超级简单
剔除就这么几行
十行代码就完成了剔除的工作
我们前面说
只有少部分的会添加到这个数组里面
对不对
那现在就从已经添加的必不可少的pass开始
一直外循环
然后从它里面拿出一个pass
然后拿出这个pass
那就设置它为零
设置为零
就是说不能被剔除
它是不能被剔除的
同时他
Producer
它的生产者
也就是说这个pass是不能被剔除的
是很重要的
那这个pass依赖的别的pass也是很重要的
那么又把它添加到这个数组里面去
那下一次这个外循环又会找出下一个
那就比如说比如说
假设我们一开始这个数组里面只有A
但是A是不是依赖了BCD
那么就会把BCD也添加进来
那比如说B又依赖了XYJ
那么到时候便利到B的时候
又会把XYJ添加进来
那你比如说Y又依赖了OBQ
那到时候用户会把OPQ添加进来
那么一直一直执行完
到最后所有的都便利完
那么就是那些所有被依赖了有用的pass
它都会设置成零
那么比如说中间有一个pass m
在整个过程中他还是执行完这个外形完
它仍然为一
说明什么
说明这个pass m是不必要的
它就被剔除掉了
所以后面我们做完这一这一步
其实我们就已经做完了剔除
那只要判断那个这个并列是一的
那就不执行这个pass咯
或者是剔除掉他了
或者是直接释放掉它或者怎么样了
那后面你看做完这一步
你看发现没有
如果是呃
这个是什么
如果如果是零就跳过
如果是一就是剔除剔除怎么样啊
不不要你了
不执行你嘛
所以你你这些什么引用啊
计算啊
就一开始是加了进去嘛
所以现在把它剪掉嘛
类似的哈
后面包括所有的执行也是一样的
跳过啊
所有的执行也是跳过啊
比如说呃这
我们看一下execute在执行的时候应该会
跳过他了
嗯应该是
上一层
你看嘛
你看他真正的去便利那些pass
准备要去执行的时候
如果发现他已经被剔除了
跳过跳过不执行了下一个
所以剔除的代码呢其实很简单哈
剔除的代码重点那就是计算那个依赖关系
而依赖关系又是根据资源
然后根据是否有输出
根基于这些来计算
然后加一开始app的时候
添加进来的时候就会掉那个setup dependency
然后就就设置好了
那这个就是图的一个重要
然后最后一点呢
IDG还有一个执行合并的功能
合并是什么意思呢
正常来说我们去执行一个pass
就是K先出手
就你前面一个pass执行完了
你的整个渲染的
比如说D3D12的那个那个pipine day啊
或者是一些设置啊
可能跟我下一个pass可能是相同的
可能是不同的
对不对
比如说可能你前面要输出到一个GBUFFA里面去
或者是另外一张八分
那这个时候我是不是要重新设置一些状态啊
或者是你前面的lander target要变成我现在的输入
或者是一些读写状态的改变
是不是要添加一个barrier屏障屏障的操作
但是也有可能你前面有个pass
跟我后面一个pass1模一样的状态一模一样
连着他给或者怎么样
大家都是读它
那是不是我就没必要去执行那些呃
评价或者是一些资源的转换啊
一个transaction的一些操作
那么这个就要去在中间
遍历所有的pass去做这样一个检查
把这些可以
没必要做中间转换的
把它缩减起来
那么这个就是所谓的pass的一个合并
那它其实是在compile
就是编译的那个函数里面去实现的
还是他他是在execute前执行的
他这个代码很强啊
他应该在这里
OK在这里这个什么merge merge merge
这个merge呢其实它是一个lambda
其实是做了一个实验
我们先把它收起来
他其实在在这一段啊
这个这个if就是去做合并merge的操作
呃也不算很长
就100多行代码
merge它其实是怎么样呢
首先呢它有个数组
就是哪些pass是可以merge的
那就会先判断如果这些pass是可以获取的
就把这些pass添加到这个数组里面来
然后添加到这个数组里面来
然后就调这个函数
这个函数就会把当前这个数组里面的所有的pass
把它设置成成功好
那它是怎么样的
就是一个for循环遍历所有的这些pass对吧
然后呃
一个for循环
然后我们看一下他怎么样
这个这个就是判断它能不能merge
它其实里面也很简单
就是这两张render target的output输出跟depth stl
跟这些状态进行一个简单的判断
比如说output是不是同一个阿婆
你必须是LTTG是一模一样的
以及这些呃状态是一样的
那他才可以
否则那就不用管了
直接return false
就那就是不能获取了
就是说两个pass能获取它的条件是很苛刻的
然后你的DESTLE是不是一样的
一样的
也是看它是不是相等
然后还有这个区域是吧
如果不行
那就直接就不能墨迹
那这个就是判断它能不能摸
也就是说这这这里呢就是一个for循环
对于这些pass
然后进行一个判断
如果可以
如果可以merge就先添加到这个数组里面来
先添加到这个数组里面来
然后当他触发到下一个已经不能墨迹了
就把当前所有这个数组里面的调一下
这个commit merge
就是说啊不能啦
就就调一下commit merge
调一下command merge
就是把这个数组里面的已经存储起来的
所有的pass merge
那他其实这里的解析呢就是很很那个
这里还有一段官方的注释
很简单啊
就是这里就是那个数组
比如说有B什么什么什么有很多
那第一个就是begin
最后一个就是中间就是叉叉叉叉叉
那么一个merge其实是要做什么呢
因为每一个pass他在执行XQ的时候
它都会有一个begin
有一个N的的一些操作
那么对于B来说
它的and呢就是不用执行的
因为这一堆都不用执行
and因为B只需要执行begin的操作
也就是说前面还有些别的pass
但是别的pass肯定跟这一组pass是不一样的
所以B要执行begin操作
但是and的操作不用
因为执行完B
你可以立即就去执行后面的值的操作
所以呢对于B的设置来说
它就是可以跳过这个N的操作
这个X呢就是不仅对于X的呢
就是begin和end都不用操作
你就直接执行X的指令
你不用做什么中间转换
所以呢对于B对于X的执行呢
它就是这个begin也可以跳过
N也可以跳过
对于一呢就是它可以跳过begin操作
但是他执行完之后
它就要到下一波别的pass了
所以an了呢他就不能跳过
按它就只能跳过begin操作
就是你可以理解在真正执行一段pass
它有三个步骤执行
有一个begin的操作啊
然后有一个真正的操作自己本身的执行
然后有一个am的操作
所以呢它会有几个布尔值
他在真真正sq的时候会有几个不值
如果能是gay就不执行
所以呢对于B来说
他是不用执行and的
对于X来说
它是begin end都不用执行
对于一来说是不用执行begin
所以其实这段注释就是很明很明确了哈
所以呢这个merge其实就是对于这个宿主
对于这个数组的头尾对头做这个操作
喂就这个操作中间的所有元素
就这些操作
然后做完操作之后就把这个数组清空
所以呢这个就是这个commit merge的实现
然后有了这个commit merge
然后就遍历所有的这些pass
然后判断一下他能不能merge
其实就是判断一下他的那个输入output
然后step stl是不是一样的
是一样的
那就可以merge
那就是把它merge掉下
这个把它添加进来掉下
那这一段代码呢
就是呃RDG里面这些pass的合并
那有了这些啊
就可以大大的对这个渲染指令
有了一个很大的优化
那这个也就是RDG的核心代码
它其实核心代码并不并不复杂
也不多
但是呢前提是你了解这个RDG
他为什么要这么做
他的目标是什么
以及它的原理是什么
看代码就很简单
不然就会好像很混乱
所以呢我非常建议大家去越在认真了哈
真的是据我个人的经验哈
把这这个官方文档好好的看一遍
是对阅读代码是非常有理解的哈
注意一些细节哈
呃那么rd g大体就是这样
RDG我们最后总结一下RDG呢
就是你首先了解一下
RDG的一些常用的接口类
一个是pass
一个是builder
然后还有一些资源handle
那么它在RDG层面
封装了一个RDG的resource
那么它对应的有RDG的
对应的有RDG的buffer
它本质上呢是封装了IHI层面的
但是呢它是延迟延迟延迟执行的
它并不是一开始就会申请那个HI
然后对于外部的外部的一些纹理
而且buffer呢它有你需要register注册进去
那就是基本的一些类的概念
那么对一些pass呢
它本身呢其实就是记录了这些pass
引用的一些资源
然后以及pass跟pass之间的一个依赖关系
那么这个依赖关系就是dependency
他是怎么去建立的
有了这个dependency的建立
那么他又是怎么去做剔除的
那就是代码不多
有了剔除
然后他还有一个合并
当剔除跟合并都执行完了
那剩下的就是按照那个异步
直接把它去sq所有的pass就可以了
那这个就是RDG的核心思路
呃那帝君呢大体就是这么多哈
应该也没有了哈
OK那我们今天就先讲这么多